[sultry industrial music]
♪ ♪
BROTHERS AND SISTERS.
- [gasps]
- AH, TONIGHT,
THE NEWEST MEMBER
OF OUR FAMILY
WILL FEAST
FOR THE FIRST TIME.
all: [hissing]
- OPHELIA...
BRING THE NEW BLOOD.
AHH.
BROTHER TYRELL.
WELCOME TO THE FIRST NIGHT
OF YOUR NEW AND--
WHAT ARE WE WEARING HERE?
- W--
UH, I-I'M JUST WEARING
WHAT I GOT BIT IN.
- MM-HMM.
OKAY.
DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING BLACK?
OR, LIKE, PANTS WITH LACES
UP THE SIDE OF THE LEG...
- [hisses]
- WOULD BE GOOD,
JUST SO YOU CAN STILL SEE
THE SKIN.
all: [gasping and hissing]
- UH, NO.
THAT'S NOT MY STYLE,
SO I AIN'T GOT NONE OF THAT
IN MY CLOSET
OR NOTHIN' LIKE THAT.
- OKAY.
ANYWAY, WE WILL TONIGHT
ALL FEAST!
all: [hissing]
- [chortles]
- COME ON, MAN.
- EXCUSE ME?
- I'M JUST SAYING,
Y'ALL OVER HERE LICKING
AND--
AND HISSING AND WHATNOT.
IF WE GONNA EAT,
THEN LET'S EAT. DAMN!
- Y-YES.
OF COURSE,
WE WILL ALL FEED.
all: [hissing]
- OKAY, YEAH, THAT'S ENOUGH.
- SPREAD THE MEAT.
crunch!
- COOL. OKAY.
DID ANY OF THAT
ACTUALLY GET IN YOUR MOUTH?
'CAUSE, I MEAN, NOW--
SHOOT.
NO WONDER Y'ALL'S HUNGRY
ALL THE TIME.
all: [hissing]
- SEE--UH-UH, UH-UH.
NO, NO, NO, NO.
SEE, LOOK,
WHY Y'ALL GOTTA HISS
WHEN YOU FLASHIN' YOUR FANGS?
YOU KNOW YOU CAN MAKE
YOUR TEETH COME OUT
WITHOUT DOING
ALL THAT NONSENSE.
SEE?
[silence]
AND CAN YOU TWO GET A ROOM?
SERIOUSLY, Y'ALL LIVE
IN A DAMN MANSION.
THERE GOTTA BE SOME OTHER PLACE
YOU COULD DO THAT [bleep].
I MEAN, ARE YOU TWO
EVEN LESBIANS?
LOOK, I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY EVERYTHING
GOTTA BE ALL SEXUAL
AND LICKY.
GIRL, SERIOUSLY, MAN.
YOU GOTTA GET YOUR HANDS
UP OFF ME
'FORE I [bleep] YOU UP.
[bleep] IS NASTY.
CREEPY AS [bleep].
BEEN TOUCHING MY NIPPLE
FOR 15 MINUTES.
ALL THIS [bleep] Y'ALL
IS DOING UP IN HERE?
THIS IS JUST, LIKE,
STRAIGHT-UP GRATUITOUS.
I GOT BIT ON PURPOSE
SO I COULD LIVE FOREVER
AND SEE FUTURE CARS.
- YEAH, CYRUS,
THESE PANTS ARE UNCOMFORTABLE.
- AND I ACTUALLY
HAVE A BOYFRIEND.
- AND THIS SONG HAS BEEN PLAYING
FOR, LIKE, TWO YEARS,
AND IT SUCKS.
- WOW.
- [sighs]
THIS JUST SEEMS...
DESPERATE.
- OKAY, DESPERATE?
REALLY, TRISTAN?
- IT'S CHRISTIAN.
- REALLY?
- HIS NAME AIN'T EVEN TRISTAN.
- SO DO YOU ALL
FEEL THIS WAY?
- YEAH.
- KINDA.
- [snorts]
WOW.
IT'S LIKE YOU CAN'T EVEN GET
GOOD FRIENDS--
NO, YOU'RE NOT EVEN--
OKAY, AND YOU'RE LEAVING NOW.
THAT'S--
- I MEAN, YOU KNOW WHAT,
DOG, SERIOUSLY,
LIKE, YOU COULD FIX
THIS PLACE UP.
IT'D BE DOPE, THOUGH.
FOR REAL.
ARE CARS GONNA BE ABLE
TO FLY,
OR IS EVERYTHING GOING TO BE
ON A MAGNETIC TRACK?
I MEAN, THAT'S WHAT
I WANT TO KNOW.
IT'S NO BIG DEAL.
- THIS O-NEGATIVE
TASTES LIKE PENNIES.
- OH, I'M SORRY ABOUT--
HEY, HEY.
NO, NO, NO, NIPPLE PLAY
IS FOR PRIVATE TIME.
- WHAT IF ALL OF THIS LIFE
WE THINK WE'RE LIVING
IS JUST A DREAM?
AND WHEN WE WAKE UP...
[voice fades out]
- THIS IS SUCH BULL[bleep],
YOU GUYS.